harry is whipped do you know the  expression i'm familiar with i won't use  the full expression but harry is whipped  like no person i think i've ever seen  i'm not a fan of megan yeah i'm not a  fan and i wasn't right from the  beginning i think poor harry is being  led around by his nose okay do you think  he's going to end i do i've been a very  good predictor as you know i've  predicted almost everything it'll end  and it'll end bad and i wonder if  harry's going to go back on his hands  and knees and say please you know i  think harry has been led down a path if  you were the queen is it at the stage  now would you remove their royal title i  would the only thing i disagree with the  queen on probably one of the only things  ever  is that i think she should have said if  that's your choice fine but you no  longer have titles you're no longer and  frankly  don't come around he has been so  disrespectful to the country and i think  he's an embarrassment